ก็สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนครับสวัสดีครับครูเอ๋
สวัสดีครับนักเรียนโอเค
นะครับผมนักเรียนคะคลิปนี้ครูเอ๋กับครู
อาร์ตี้มาคุยกันคุยกันสำหรับบีกินเนอร์ 1
ค่าอ๋อ
บีกินเนอร์ 1 ดีครับปาร์ตี้ตื่นเต้นใช่
ไหม
วันนี้วันนี้ได้มาอัดคลิปกับครูเอ๋ด้วย
ตื่นเต้นตื่นเต้นเลยวันนั้น
แรกครั้งแรกๆทรายขาวเป็นตอนเพลแต่ว่าไม่
มีอัดคลิปจริงๆๆ
ครับได้โอเคค่ะครู Arty ครับวันนี้วัน
อะไรคะอ้าวันนี้วันที่เรามาอัดคลิปกันวัน
นี้เมื่อวันที่ 28 ครับหน้าวันนี้มี 28
วันที่ 28 วันที่วันนี้เป็นวันอะไรคะอ๋อ
อ๋อวันที่ 28 เป็นวันพฤหัสบดีครับ 5 วัน
พฤหัสบดีที่
28 หน้าโอเคงั้นวันนี้วันพฤหัสบดีวันที่
28 เดือนอะไรคะอ๋อเดือนนี้เดือนนี้เดือน
ตุลาคมครับเดือนตุลาคมปีพตเท่าไหร่คะ
เดือนตุลาคมปีพตต
2564 ครับ
ปีพศ
2560  4-5 ปีพศ.นะคะเมื่อปีคศปีคศ
2000  21 ครับ
ใช้ 21 ครู Arty คะแล้วตอนนี้เวลากี่โมง
คะตอนนี้ใช่ไหมครับตอนนี้เวลา 5 ตอนนี้
เวลา
18:00 น 50 นาที
กลางวันหรือกลางคืนอ๋อเป็นเส้น
อาฮะ 5 เป็นกลางวันกลางวันหาตอนนี้
กลางวันแต่เป็นตอนเย็นตอนเย็นแล้วค่อย
ครับใช่มั้ยต่อหน้า
18:00 น
55 นาทีค่ะ 5 แค่ 5 นี้ครูเอ๋กับครู Arty
ก็มาเจอกันเริ่มต้นกันนะคะให้ครับตอนนี้
18:00 น 20 นาทีให้ใกล้มืออ้าใช่ครับ
ใกล้มือบางคนกำลังกินข้าวค่า
ครับคิวหิวผู้หิวก่อนท้อง
ท้องหิวหิวหิวใช่ไหมโอเคอ่าน้องก็จะมี
เสียงเจ้า
หิว
หิวหิวแล้ววันนี้กูอัดที่มีใครที่คิวอยู่
คะอ่ามีใครหิวโอเคนะได้ยินครูอาร์ทตี้
เนี่ยจะมีใครไม่รู้มาแล้วก็คิวห่าใช่ๆวัน
นี้ครัวตี้มีมีครับให้เรามาดูไปพร้อมๆกัน
ว่าใครใครนะที่กำลังหิวอ่าโอเคอะตีคะอะ
ตี้คิดว่าตอนนี้นักเรียนที่ดูเรากำลังหิว
มั้ยฮ่าๆนักเรียนหิวไหมครับตอนนี้
คอมเมนต์ไหมคอมเม้นท์บอกแล้วว่าคิวไหมไอ้
ห่ากูอัดลี่คิวไม่คะน่ากลัวตีตอนนี้ครัว
ตี้ไม่หิวไม่หิวกูอะติ๊กกิน
กินข้าวเสร็จแล้วใช่ควรที่กินข้าวแล้ว
ครับไม่หิวกินแล้วตอนนี้อิ่มอิ่มอ่ะ
ไม่หิวครับโหเหี๊ย
ยังไม่ได้กินข้าวอ๋อออซอยังไม่ได้กิน
อ่านแล้วไปครูเอ๋
รออีก 1 ชั่วโมงกินอ่ะอ้าวโอเคถ้างั้น
เดี๋ยวเรามาเรียนกันก่อนนะก็อ่าละก็จะไป
ดูว่าใครมามาแล้วอ้าใครมามาดูกันนะครับ
อยากกินอ่านี่ครับมาและเอามาแล้ว
อะไรคะเนี่ย 5 นี่นี่ตัวอะไรใช่ไหมครับ
ตัวอะไรครับเนี่ยอะไรนักเรียนรู้จักไหม
ครับตัวนี้ตัวอะไรครับ 5 อะไรอ่ะเรียนรู้
จักภาษาอังกฤษแต่นักเรียนไม่รู้จักภาษา
ไทยขอ
อภัยเนี่ยพูดว่าอะไรคะหาตัวนี้ภาษาไทยพูด
ว่าสิงโต
โตในครับสิงโต
หางโจมีผมด้วยนะคะใช่ครับสิงโตมีผมโตมีผม
ยาว
ข้าวใช่ไหมอ้าวใจเขาผมยาวนะคะ 555 กูเอก
ก็ผมยาวผมยาวอ้อผมคู๋เหมือน
หัวสิงโตหาดทรายครับแต่สิงโตสิงโตผมสี
อะไรครับสีน้ำตาลหาชายสิงโตสระผมสีน้ำตาล
c5 ชายานี่สีน้ำตาลใช่ครับอ่าแต่ผมคู๋สี
อะไรครับผมครูเอ๋สีดำอ๋อโอเคสีดำใช้ค่ะผม
สิงโตสีน้ำตาลอ่ะไม่เหมือนกันไม่เหมือน
กันใช่เรื่องผสมแค่นั้นฮ่าๆมีสีเหลือง
ด้วย
เหลืองด้วยนิดหน่อย
ฮ่าๆๆ
สิงโตจริงๆสิงโตต้องมีเขี้ยวฮ่าๆเสือ
สิงโตต้องมีเกี่ยวแต่ตัวนี้ไม่มีเที่ยว
อ่ะตอนนี้โดนใจดีตายใจดีใจดีๆเขาตอบมีแขน
ไหมคะอ้าสิงโตมีแขนแต่แขนของสิงโตเรา
เรียกว่าขาอ๋องั้นโตก็ไม่มีแขนอ้าน้อใช่
ไหมคะสิงโตมีแต่ขา
สาๆโตมีขากี่ขาคะหน้าสิงโตมี 4 ขาครับ
สิงโตมีขา 4 ขาใต้นะคะหน้าตรงนี้มี 1 ขา
นี่แล้วนี้สองขาค่ะ 3 ขาแล้วก็มีตรงนี้
อีกนะครับตรงนี้สี่ขาอ่าสิงโตมีขา 4 ขา
สิงโตตกขา 4 ขา
มาแล้วสิงโตมีเล็บไหมคะ
สิงโตมีเล็บเหมือนกันสิงโตก็มีเล็บใช่
ครับ 5 มีเล็บอยู่ตรงนี้
อ้า
แหลมไหมคะแหลมสิงห์โตมีเล็บแหลมครับมี
เล็บแหลมมากน้าแหลมอยู่ตรงนี้ใช่
ใช่
อีเลฟแหลมทุกนิ้วเลยมีนิ้วทุกนิ้วมีเล็บ
แหลม
ทุกครั้งเลยใช่ครับมีเล็บแหลมๆครับเวลา
สิงโต
โกรธก็จะยกขาขึ้นชายกับกบ 5
ตอนที่โกรธตอนที่โปรดสิงโตก็จะโกหกแล้วก็
เอาเล็บออกมาจ่ายครับ
โอ้โหสิงโตมีหางไหมคะใช่สิงโตมีห่างด้วย
ครับอยู่ตรงนี้ครับหางสิงโตว้าวสิงโตสั้น
หรือยาวอ้านี่สิงโตหางยาวหางยาวออกมาตรง
นี้เลยนี่
ยาว 5 สิงห์โตหางยาวขา 555 ข้อแต่สิงโต
สิงโตของครู Arty ครูเอ๋ดูแล้วเนี่ยตาใช่
มั้ยปลาสิงโต
หน้าสิงโตนะหิวจังเลยตายตอนนี้สิงโตหิว
ยังไม่ได้กินทางไม่ได้กินเลยหิวแล้วครู
อาร์ทตี้มีอาหารให้สิงโตเรือดกินไหมคะๆมี
อาหารมาให้สิงโตเลือกด้วยเอ้ยว่าสิงโตจะ
ชอบกินอาหารที่เอามาให้ไหมงั้นอาหารจาน
แรกคือมีอะไรคะจานแรกที่จะเอามาให้สิงโต 5
อ่ะก็คืออ่าอันนี้ครับอะไรคะนั้นน่ะอาหาร
นี้นี่คือนี่คือน้ำผึ้งน้ำหน้าชายครับน้ำ
ผึ้งอันนั้นนะพึ่งแล้วที่ใส่อันนั้นเป็น
เป็นขวดแล้วนะอันนี้เป็นรางผึ้งรังผึ้ง
ายคราฟหน้า
แล้วอ่า
ขึ้นเป็นยังไงคะ 5 กูอีกว่าให้ไหมเสียหาย
กูเองว่า
EVA ก็
จะเป็นแบบนี้มีตัวพึ่งนี่ครับอ่าพึ่งแล้ว
ก็มีปีกมีปีกหนี้อ้าพึ่งกว่าที่อนันต์
พึ่งหรอหาให้ครับนาที่เอ็ฟเฟ็กว่างเลยอ่ะ
เดี๋ยวคะเดี๋ยวมันพึ่งมันผีเสื้อหรือมัน
แมลงปอ
ปีกเล็กๆที่กำลังบินอยู่นี่บินอยู่เร็วๆ
ตัวใหญ่มากหรือเพิ่งจะเป็นแบบนี้อิอิฮ่าๆ
อันนี้ไม่เหมือนพึ่ง
โอเคอันนี้โอเคได้แล้วคุยช่วยตัวเองช่วย
อ๋อโอเคจะว่าพึ่งให้เหมือนใช่ไหมอ้าว
เดี๋ยวกูเอาไปให้นะคะ
เพิ่งสีน้ำตาลเนาะคุยว่าได้ไหมได้ครับอ่า
ตอนนี้เห็นแล้ว
อ๋อมีหัวกลมๆๆอาจจะมีจะมีหน่อยแล้วก็มี
ปีกปีกเล็กๆค่ะพึ่งอ่าแล้วก็จะมีป่าเนาะ
เหมือนไหมหวัดดีคนอาทิไม่น่าจะ
เดี๋ยวเอม่อนตี้ดูแลมาแล้วรู้แล้วว่าพึ่ง
เป็นยังไงก็ไม่รู้แล้ว
อ๋ออ๋ออ้าตัวสีเหลืองมีลาย
กำไลมีมีตรงนี้ด้วยอ่า
อ๋อได้ครับพี่ขาไม่รู้เหมือนไม่ได้พึ่ง
ง่อพึ่งมีขาด้วยนะ
เพิ่งครูเอ๋
โอเคเหมือนๆกูอตตี้นะ
กินไหมสิงโตสิงโตอยากกินน้ำผึ้งไหมครู and
สิงโตไม่กินน้ำผึ้งอ้าวน้ำทำไมมีสี
น้ำผึ้งเป็นอาหารของหมีขอ
น้ำผึ้ง
เป็นอาหารของหมีสิงโตก็เลยถ้าไม่กิน
สิงโตที่ว่าโดนจะร้องไห้แล้ว
ว่าฟิล์มต่อมั้ยกินน้ำผึ้งอาถ้างั้นไม่
เอาไม่เอาน้ำผึ้งใช่ไหมว่าสิงโตไม่กินไม่
กินน้ำผึ้งค่ะ 5 สิงโตเนี่ยอ่ะดิเขาไม่
กินน้ำผึ้งมีอาหารพึ่งใช่
นานแล้วจานที่สองไหมคะอาหารจานที่ 2 มี
ครับอะไรคะอ่ะนี่ครับอาหารจานที่ 2 มีไร้
นี่คือพริกหวานครับหน้าศาลพิหวาน
สิงโตกินพริกหวานไหมทีมไหมสิงโตคิดอยู่
คุณอาตี้สิงโตสิงโตกำลังคิดว่าก็จะกินไหม
อีกจุดหมายได้คู่เองเนี่ยมีไก่ก็มีไก่ไก่
กินพริกหวานใช่ไก่บอกว่าในก็บอกผิวของ
ขวาน
ว่าอาไก่กินพริกหวานสิงโตไม่กินพริกหวาน
ใช่สิงโตไม่กินพริกหวานค่ะอ้าวพริกหวาน
ไม่กินน้ำผึ้งไม่กินค่ะครูอาติ๊กกินพริก
หวานไหมคะ 5 ครูโยตี้กินครับกินพริกหวาน
แล้วดู Arty กินน้ำครึ่งไหมคะน้ำผึ้งครัว
ที่ก็กินอ่าหัวตี้กินพริกหวานแล้วก็กิน
น้ำผึ้งด้วยเเต่สิงโตสิงโตไม่กินพริกหวาน
สิงโตไม่กินน้ำผึ้งแต่
ว่าเราก็อาจดีและกู Arty ชอบน้ำผึ้งหรือ
ชอบคลิกกวาดคะครัวตี้ท่อบพริกหวาน
และถามน้ำครึ่งชอบไหมคะน้ำผึ้งชอบนิด
หน่อย
ครูเอ๋เอ๋ชอบน้ำผึ้งมอบพริกหวานขอถ้าชอบ
สองอย่างเลยถ้าหายสองอย่างเลยอ่ะพริกกว่า
แล้วก็น้ำผึ้งคุณเอ๋ชอบกินน้ำผึ้งชอบกิน
พริกหวานนะคะถ้า
สิงโตสิงโตมาให้ชอบสิงโตไม่ชอบสิงโตตกใจ
เฮ้ยกินไม่ได้สิงโตกินไม่ได้
ก็ได้งั้นครูบาติ๊บต้องมีจานที่ 3 ค่ะ
อ้าวพี่ไหมคะทานที่ 3 อีกมีครับมีจานที่ 3
จานที่สามเป็นอะไรคะอ่าอาจารย์ที่ 3 นี่
จะหานที่ 3 มาแล้วครับอะไรคะมีนมนมหน่อย
ครับนมมเดี๋ยวนะคะครู Arty เราครับหาครู
เคมีมีตัวอะไรตัวอะไรมากินนมครับไม่นมอัน
นี้หนูมานมแพะและนมแพ้ขอนมแพ้หรือว่านมไป
ไหนของครูเอ๋วัววัววัวนมวัวๆนมวัวหรือนม
แพะใช่อัวอันที่วัดวัวได้ไหมคะวัววิ่งไป
เที่ยวไหนแล้วอ่ะ a  f นี้ครูเอ๋ไปแล้ว
ตัวหนีไปแล้วพี่แต่เสือเดี๋ยวนะคะ
คู๋ร้องมา
วอ
[เพลง]
นักเรียนวัวเนี่ยร้องหมอนาย
มอเตอร์วัวไม่อยู่กับตัวมาไม่มีแต่ควาย
ๆไม่เป็นไรหนออ๋อโอเคไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่นมแพะ
ไม่ใช่นะคะถ้าไม่ใช่นมแพ้โอเคแต่นมแพะ
สิงโตกินนมไหมสิงโตกินนมไหมครับนักเรียน
คิดสิงโตกินกินไหม
คู่ a คิดนะครู Arty คุณคิดคิดๆหน้าสิงโต
คะเด็กๆ
อ๋อต้มสิงโตเด็กๆตัวเล็กๆใช่ไหมตัวเล็กๆ
น่าใช้ครับแบบนี้สิงโตตัวใหญ่อ๋อตัวใหญ่
แล้วแม่กินนม
Single หิวหิว
ยังไม่ได้กิน
hi  end นานมก็ไม่กินอ่ะปิ๊กหวานค่ะก็
ไม่กินค่ะน้ำผึ้งก็ไม่กินก็แล้วสิงโต
สิงโตยังหิวอยู่ยังไม่ได้กินแล้วครู Arty
กินนมไหมคะฮ่าๆๆทรู Arty กินขาวดีเห็นนม
โอเคงั้นน้ำผึ้งไม่กินสิงโตเตือนให้กิน
น้ำผึ้งน้ำโตไม่กินพริกหวานชายเขาไม่กิน
นมต้องมีอาหารจานที่ 4 ค่ะไหมคะอาหารจาน
ที่ 4 การนี้กลัวดิคิดว่าสิงโตต้องชอบ
ต้องชอบจานที่ 4 ค่ะถ้ามีอะไรคะจาน
อาจารย์ที่ 4 อันที่ 4 คือ
จานที่ 4 คือนี่
อะไรคะกู Arty มีคือเนื้อครับ 5 เนื้อแท้
สายขาวแล้วสิงโตกินไหมเนื้อ
สิงโตยิ้มแล้วค่ะครูอัด
สิงโตยิ้มเลยยิ้มออกแล้วที่มีบอกว่าหิว
น้ำผึ้งน้ำผึ้งคนที่ชีน้ำผึ้งให้หน่อยน้ำ
ท่าน้ำฮะซึ่งอันนี้ไม่กินไม่กิน
หวานซี้หวานไม้กินนมกินไหมนมไม่กิน
งานสิงโตโต๊ะมองเห็นหน้าโหเฮงสิงโตเป็น
ยังไงคะสิงโตชอบสิงโตกินจะกินเนื้อ on
สิงโตยิ้มหิวหาดๆสาว
อ๋ออ๋อสิงโตกินเนื้อ
อ้าวกินหมดไหมคะ 5 กินหมดเลยเพราะว่า
สิงโตหิวหิวมากหิวมากกินหมดเลยสิงโตก็กิน
นะคะเนื้อเข้าไปที่ปากอ่อนเนื้อเข้าไปที่
ปากสิงโตฮ่าๆๆเข้าดึกเข้าไปเอาไปสิงโตล่ะ
ครับก็ยังไม่ได้โอเคไม่เป็นไรอ่ะสิงโตกิน
ห้าสีตรงอินเสร็จแล้วเป็นยังไงคะหน้ายก
นี้เสร็จแล้วสิงโตก็จะอิ่มทีมได้ครับ
เหมือนครัวตีกวนตีก็กินข้าวแล้วครัวนี่ก็
อิ่มตอนนี้อิ่มชายครับกูอันตี้ขาเป๋นะดู
แล้วมีอะไรนะมีน้ำครึ่งหน้ามีน้ำผึ้งมี
พริกหวานมีพิษหวานมีนมนมแล้วก็มีเนื้อ
เนื้อเนื้อกับไอ้สิงโตเนี่ยดูแล้วก็เลือก
กินหากูอะตี้ในอิ่มแต่กู a นะหิวฮ่าๆตัว
ตีเอ้ยผู้เอกยังไม่ได้กินขวดถ้วยเอ๋ยัง
หิวอยู่อยู่นานกว่าที่อิ่มสิงโตก็อิ่มนะ
อุ้ยเทียนหิว kuai หิวแล้วนักเรียนขิว
หรือนักเรียนอิ่มมือหิวหรืออิ่มครับหน้า
นักเรียนบอกครูด้วยนะคะขิวอิ่มแล้วนัก
เรียนกินน้ำผึ้งไหมน่ากินไหมครับกินไหม
น้ำผึ้งคอมเม้นข้างล่างนะคะคะคอมเม้นท์
ไว้นะตัวตีกินผู้เอกก็กินน้ำผึ้งอ้ะนัก
เรียนกินไหมถ้าๆและนักเรียนกินพริกหวาน
ไหมคะโอ้มีพิษหวานด้วยอ่าครัวตี้กินพริก
หวานที่เอ๋ก็กิน pic ขวานะอ่านักเรียนล่ะ
ครับนักเรียนกินพริกหวานไหม 5 แล้วก็มีนม
ครูเอ๋ไหมกินนมหมอครูเอ๋ไม่กินนมๆพี่น้อง
ควยตี้กินควร Chic  I  No  money นมใต้
แล้วนักเรียนล่ะครับนักเรียนกินนมไหม
พี่กินเนื้อไหมคะเนื้อน่ากลัวตี้กลัวติ๊ก
in เหนือครับน่ากินเนื้อค่ะถ้าครูเอ๋ไม่
กินเนื้อขอไหมกินเนื้อถ้างั้นกลัวติ๊กกิน
เนื้อสิงโตสิงโตอ้วกเอาะกินเนื้ออาบาก้
เรียนนักเรียนกินเนื้อไหมและเปลี่ยนกิน
เนื้อไหมครับถ้านักเรียนกินเนื้อไหมหรือ
ไม่กินก็
คอมเม้นท์
เอ๋รู้หน้าวัดเหนือไหมนะคะครูแอนตี้คะตอน
นี้ครับอิ่มอาคิด
สิงโตอยากจะนอนขออยากจะนอนแล้วแม่ทีมแล้ว
อยากจะนอนใช่แล้วก็คิดว่านักเรียนนะอยาก
จะไปกินอาหารฮ่าๆๆเหมือนครูเอ๋ครูเอกค่อย
ฉากจะไปเห็นอาหารครูเอ๋หิวปัญหาเพราะอา
น้ำผึ้ง
คลิปกว่าสาร
นมแน่เนื้อๆทั้งหมดพูดว่าอาหารขอ
ทั้งบอร์ดหน้าทั้งหมดคืออาหาร
ชายเป็นอาหารครับวันนี้ครูเอกกับครู
ปาร์ตี้ต้องไปก่อนเนาะเพราะครูหิวมาก
หิวจริงๆโอเคอ่าเดี๋ยวกูเอ๋จะไปกินกินน้ำ
ผึ้งใช่ไหมกินแล้วพีคหวานหวานๆตั้งค่า
ขอบคุณนะคะครู Arty ขอบคุณครับขอบคุณเช่น
กันครับผมขอบคุณครูเอ๋ก่อนหน้าแล้วก็
ขอบคุณนักเรียนสวัสดีนักเรียนสวัสดีครู
เอ๋ด้วยครับ
นะเดี๋ยวคราวหน้าเจอกันบ๊ายบาย